BA YAH AND IT'S OVER.
THIS IS INCREDIBLY
COMPLICATED.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE TIME.
>> Mike: WITH THAT I'M GOING
TO TAKE A DEEP BREATH AND
BRING IN OUR PANEL.
STEVE HAYES EDITOR AND CHIEF
FOR THE.
KAREN TUMULTY AND OPINION
WRITER FOR THE "WASHINGTON
TIMES."
STEVE, DOES IT HAPPEN.
>> I THINK THERE WILL BE
SOME KIND OF A SUMMIT.
YOU I DON'T THINK IT'S
LIKELY IN THE COMING MONTHS.
IT WAS SMART FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO TAKE A STEP
BACK HERE.
HE SEEMED AT LEAST IN HIS
PUBLIC COMMENTS VERY EAGER
FOR NOT ONLY THE SUMMIT BUT
FOR A DEAL SAYING THINGS
ABOUT KIM JONG UN THAT I
DON'T THINK WERE TRUE GIVING
HIM TOO MUCH RESPECT SAYING
WEIGHS VERY OPEN AND VERY
HONORABLE.
AT ONE POINT THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED THAT KIM JONG UN HAD
AGREED TO DENUCLEARIZATION,
WHICH HE HADN'T.
SO I THINK IT'S SMART THAT
THE PRESIDENT TOOK A STEP
BACK HERE.
I THINK HE HAD MIKE POMPEO
AND JOHN BOLTON IN HIS EAR
REMINDING HIM OF THE HISTORY
OF OF THE NORTH KOREAN
BEHAVIOR ON THIS.
THE HISTORY REALLY MATTERS.
IT'S NOT AS IF KIM JONG UN'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO GIVE UP
HIS NUCLEAR WEAPONS PROGRAM.
IT'S BEEN A KEY COMPONENT OF
THE REGIME FOR THREE
DECADES.
IT WILL REMAIN A KEY
COMPONENT OF THE REGIME AND
ANYTHING HAS TO START WITH
THAT PREMISE, I THINK.
>> Mike: SPEAKING OF
PRESIDENTIAL TWEETS.
WE HAVE ONE HERE.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING VERY
GOOD NEWS TO RECEIVE THE
WARM AND PRODUCTIVE
STATEMENT FROM NORTH KOREA.
WE WILL SOON SEE WHERE IT
LEADS.
HOPEFULLY LONG AND ENDURING
PROSPERITY AND PEACE.
ONLY TIME AND TALENT WILL
TELL.
AND SARAH SANDERS THE PRESS
SECRETARY ALSO PROVIDED THIS
UPDATE.
>> AS THE PRESIDENT SAID
THIS MORNING CERTAINLY WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
MEETING.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT JUST
LOOKING TO HAVE A MEETING.
HE IS NOT LOOKING FOR JUST A
CHEAP POLITICAL STUNT.
HE WANTS TO GET SOMETHING
THAT'S A LONG-LASTING AND
ACTUAL REAL SOLUTION.
THOUGHTS AT THIS STAGE.
>> OF COURSE WE SHOULD ALL
BE ROOT FOR A LONG LASTING
AND REAL SOLUTION.
IT'S NOT ONLY TIME AND
TALENT.
I WOULD HOPE THE
ADMINISTRATION, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY HAVE
LEARNED IS THAT THE OTHER
TWO THINGS THAT YOU NEED
GOING INTO THIS KIND OF
MEETING ARE PREPARATION AND
MESSAGE DISCIPLINE.
AND BOTH OF THOSE THINGS
REALLY SEEM TO BE LACKING.
STARTING FROM THE MOMENT
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED THAT THE SUMMIT
WAS HAPPENING WITHOUT
CONSULTING HIS FOREIGN
POLICY ADVISORS OR, YOU
KNOW, HIS OWN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Mike: CHARLIE, YOUR
THOUGHTS AT THIS STAGE?
>> I THINK IT'S INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW, TO LISTEN TO.
SO DEMOCRATS COMPLAIN ABOUT.
SO STRATEGY HERE.
I THINK IT'S POLITICALLY
TONE DEAF.
BECAUSE AS YOU SAY, KAREN,
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE ROOTING
FOR SOME SUCCESS HERE.
AND THE NOTION THAT YOU HAVE
SOME DEMOCRATS, OBVIOUSLY
JUST MAKING A PARTISAN
CLAIM.
CRITICIZING THE PRESIDENT
FOR EVEN HAVING THE MEETING.
AND GIVING HIM SO -- KIM
JONG UN SOME STATURE HE
SHOULDN'T HAVE HAD.
MY GOODNESS WE JUST WENT
THROUGH 8 YEARS OF NOT ONLY
WHATEVER THEY CALLED IT, THE
STRATEGIC INDIFFERENCE IN
KOREA BUT ALSO THE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH IRAN.
THE PROBLEM WASN'T THAT THEY
WERE NEGOTIATING WITH IRAN.
IT'S THAT THEY FELL FOR A
TERRIBLE DEAL.
AND OF COURSE, JOHN KERRY,
DURING THAT TIME WAS SO
DESPERATE TO GET A DEAL, HE
PRACTICALLY MOVED IN WITH
THE FOREIGN MINISTER OF
IRAN.
AND WOUND UP WITH A REALLY,
REALLY BAD DEAL.
SO THAT'S THE PROBLEM THERE.
SO I THINK TO STEP BACK NOW
AND HAVE DEMOCRATS ALMOST
GLEEFUL WHEN THE TALKS GOT
CALLED OFF, IT IS A -- THEY
ARE TONE DEAF AGAIN
POLITICALLY SPEAKING.
>> Mike: WAS SOME OF THIS
THE ART OF THE DEAL.
YOU SOUGHT PRESIDENT PULL
OUT YESTERDAY AND THE NORTH
KOREANS LAST NIGHT AROUND
NEWS TIME WERE SAYING WAIT A
MINUTE, WE WOULD STILL LIKE
TO TALK.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT AT
LEAST DESERVES SOME RUNNING
ROOM HERE FOR IT BEING
EXACTLY THAT AND TO HAVE,
YOU KNOW, SOMEBODY LIKE BOB
THEN THEN DID HE SEE
LECTURING US, MIKE POMPEO
YESTERDAY ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
THE ART OF THE DEAL IS NOT
THE SAME OF THE ART OF
DIPLOMACY.
MY GOODNESS, I MEAN, THE
EXPERTS HAVE BEEN IN CHARGE
FOR A LONG TIME.
WHAT DO WE HAVE?
WE HAVE A NUCLEAR NORTH
KOREA AND NEARLY A NUCLEAR
IRAN.
SO, OBVIOUSLY, MAYBE
SWITCHING IT UP AND TRYING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT MIGHT
NOT BE A BAD IDEA.
>> Mike: KAREN, DO YOU THINK
WE WILL BE BACK AND FORTH
AND BACK AND FORTH ON
WHETHER THIS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE COMING WEEKS?
>> YES, I DO.
HOWEVER, YOU KNOW, ONE THING
WE HAVE ALSO LEARNED, I
THINK, FROM THIS IS THAT,
YOU KNOW, WHEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS RUNNING FOR
OFFICE.
HE SAID I LIKE TO BE
UNPREDICTABLE.
HE HAS, I THINK, DISCOVERED
THAT, YOU KNOW, CAN YOU
OVERDO UNPREDICTABILITY AS
WELL.
>> Mike: STEVE, WE HAVE SEEN
A BIT OF A DYNAMIC OF MIKE
POMPEO, PERHAPS, BEING THE
GOOD COP IN THESE
NEGOTIATIONS AND THEN JOHN
BOLTON BEHIND THE SCENES
PERHAPS BEING THE BAD COP.
IS THAT YOUR READ OF THINGS?
>> WELL, IF HAVE YOU GOT
MIKE POMPEO BEING THE GOOD
COP ON NORTH KOREA.
THAT'S A PRETTY HAWKISH
PLACE TO BE.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT MIKE
POMPEO IS GIVING THE
PRESIDENT ADVICE THAT
SUGGESTS HE TAKE SERIOUSLY
THIS LONG HISTORY THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER AND NOT
FALL FOR ANY PUBLIC GESTURES
THAT KIM JONG UN MIGHT
ENGAGE.
IN LOOK, POMPEO KNOWS
ARGUABLY MORE ABOUT THIS
THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
HE HAS BEEN THERE AND MET
WITH HIM.
I THINK HE HAS A GOOD SENSE
OF WHAT THE ACTUAL ASK WAS.
WHAT THE REAL CONVERSATIONS
WERE BETTER THAN ANYBODY
ELSE.
HE IS ALSO, I THINK, QUITE
AWARE OF THIS HISTORY AND
THE HISTORY IS WHAT HAS TO
BE OUR GUIDE AS WE GO INTO
THESE DISCUSSIONS.
>> HOW DO YOU SEE THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS.
>> I THINK KAREN IS RIGHT.
I SUSPECT IT WILL BE
UNPREDICTABLE ANDED A HAWK.
IT CAN BE ADVANTAGEOUS TO BE
UNPREDICTABLE WITH YOUR.
IT'S NOT GOOD TO HAVE OUR
ALLIES SPUN UP AND INTO
BEWILDERMENT ANNOUNCEMENT
LIKE THIS.
IMPORTANT TO KEEP THEM ON
BOARD AND TALK TO OTHERS
THAT NEED TO BE SUPPORTING
WHAT WE ARE DOING IN THESE
TALKS.
>> Mike: IN THE END DOES THE
DEAR LEADER WALK AWAY FROM
THE TABLE?
>> THE THING IS ONE THING WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IS WHAT
THESE NUCLEAR WEAPONS MEAN
TO KIM JONG UN.
AND THEY ARE LITERALLY TIED
TO HIS ACTUAL, PHYSICAL
SURVIVAL.
SO, I THINK THAT, AGAIN, WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THIS IS
NOT THE PRESIDENT KEEPS
SAYING WELL, WE COULD BRING
YOU ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND
WE COULD GUARANTEE YOUR
SAFETY.
KIM JONG UN KNOWS HE HAS GOT
SAFETY AND THOSE ARE THOSE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> CHARLIE, BRIEFLY, DO YOU
EXPECT A RESULT.